i think that
when you're committed to something you
want to make sure that it's right for
you the inner conviction has to be
so strong so
i'm passionate about it i have a spark
in my eye that's what i want to do for
for the next 10 years and and
i think
for us it was
so important to make sure that
we did it with
kind of eyes wide open that's what we
want to be that's where be bringing
value to our customers
and i think that journey
made us a lot more uh whole right a lot
more
mature about the idea about what we're
going to do for for many years now
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tec
welcome to a very special episode of
20-minute leaders meet offer ben nunn a
great friend and co-founder and ceo of
talon cyber security offer is a seasoned
entrepreneur with vast cyber security
experience he is the founder and ceo of
talon cyber security talent is
reinventing cyber security for the
distributed workforce by creating a
secure and isolated browser-centric work
environment for enterprises
prior to talon he was the founder and
ceo of argus the global leader in
automotive cyber security which was
acquired by continental in 2017
following the acquisition he served as a
member of senior management at
continental and as ceo of argus leading
it to protect over 60 million vehicles
globally ofer served as captain in the
idf cyber intelligence unit 8200 and was
a team member of two israel defense
prize-winning projects
20-minute leaders how are you
such a privilege to be part of the
journey getting to know you through the
different milestones and such a pride in
the you know in the israeli ecosystem
with the work that you've done with with
argus cyber security and in automotive
cyber security selling for the 400
million dollars now working on a new
startup and we'll see also an incredible
co-founder on just as an important
problem if not even more important
in the work from home and you know time
span
if you look at your journey of phil how
do you define who you are are you a ceo
an entrepreneur a cyber guy
i think more than anything uh
i want to see myself as a problem solver
because
generally speaking
it's all about
challenges and how you address them in
the most efficient way
practical
helpful for customers so generally
speaking about solving problems
any leader generally you know you are
not needed when there are no problems
right and and
as long as you've built your team right
then it means that the law that you are
able to lower the amount of challenges
that you are actually required to be
involved in so
for entrepreneurship is is how do you
make sure that they are the least amount
of things that you really need to solve
and when you are required how are you
able to get to the most efficient time
wise budget wise uh satisfaction wise
for for the customer
solutions
if you're looking back at your journey
with argus
you know what was that like
you know building a cyber security
company growing it
beautifully within tel aviv
many employees creating a lot of value
and then selling the ecosystem
when you look back at that you know that
whole journey what are you reflecting on
what stands out in your mind
i think betting on something that
wasn't trivial so kind of creating a
category
for something that most people say why
would anyone ever want to hack your
vehicle
why would it be interesting for anyone
why will
anyone will ever think that there is
something big enough here uh um
now it's trivial back then and now it's
trivial but back then uh it was late
we've spoken at a time for about
13 different funds uh for sabram
wow
almost all of them said look
it could be you're an amazing team but
we're not sure that automotive cyber
security
will
ever be
a topic
right so the ability kind of to move
forward to think
um to have the vision of understanding
look that's where the world is work is
going um this is the vacuum this is the
gap that's where i want to invest the
the next few years of my life
for me this is kind of
a
a big vision
a bit because it's always a bit right it
could have been that there would have
been
no interest that no communication right
and since the execution right building
the right team to address this problem
that is a
versatile
able kind of
to move quickly to change and cease is
dispassionate about uh solving this
problem
argus is becoming a success story in the
israel ecosystem
and where are you at i remember we took
a walk
post argus pre-talent
and i was walking with a person who was
constantly thinking about
what else does the world need
and figuring out where are you in this
landscape because you've
made it already you've achieved what
every young entrepreneur wants to
achieve
and i kept trying to understand you know
what is going on in your mind and your
heart what was going on during that time
frame
i think we were
it was somewhere
middle of last year i think it was
somewhere
middle of 2020
and
this was when when quad and i were
starting to to discuss and think about
it so uh one more of my my co-founder
today talon we know each other from 80
to 100 days right
crazy to think it's about 15 years ago
oh my god yeah time flies
and your name still resonates in the
halls of the buildings i can tell you
that
thank you and and
i think that kind of
uh the opportunity to work with was was
really unique so that
uh was the coffin of cool mobile
security it was the first cyber solution
for smartphones acquired by checkpoint
in 2015
and
when one came back uh to israel in in
middle of uh 2020 uh uh thanks to kobe
obviously um the opportunity to work
with them together on building something
was something that
obviously i i don't have every day and
we started to think together what can we
bring to the world right what is the
biggest value or the biggest solution
that we can solve is without skill set
because
in a sense
i think that after we've been fortunate
to be successful one time
it's
our
maybe interstate obligation to the world
cup to be something that brings value
right but it wasn't trivial exactly what
it was going to be it wasn't trivial
that you're going to go back into cyber
security no not at all you're right
actually um
initially we really wanted to be outside
of stuff so we looked everything around
cyber and
we really want to be actually digital
healthcare wow yeah at the time
we looked at
how
can we really make the life of people
better uh
save potentially
people's lives and the world that we're
looking at was actually literal
pathology
because
kind of something that was really
interesting for us is that there are a
few processes in the world of healthcare
that computer must be doing a lot better
and and one of that is is pathology
because identifying patterns is
something that the human mind is
obviously uh not as good as as computer
capabilities so we started to look into
this world um but unfortunately more and
more we understood that still the
ecosystem of national healthcare
we didn't feel it was
that receptive
to fantastic technology so the
challenges around
uh
networking
of this ecosystem the receptiveness
we felt that even if we bring a
fantastic solution
and the chances for that to make the
impact that we wanted
um
wasn't that uh uh i would say like
this rigorous thinking though and it's
revelation as to okay we know there's a
huge pain point which usually would be
enough for somebody to go and start a
company but you added this extra layer
of playing sort of a simulation from so
i guess a more mature understanding of
the market understanding of how things
play out
how is that experience do you think
because you had each of you had unique
experiences as entrepreneurs did that
add to sort of the thinking process and
their ideation
i would say the biggest blessing of the
first time entrepreneur is the naive
yeah
and
in a sense
i i i guess that was not something this
may even say right so the way that we
now doesn't mean the curse that's
sneakers yes and and
we try kind of to identify yourself what
are the key things that
we want to see in in in adventure right
and for us the first number one will be
impact of the world how much value does
it bring to people uh when we look 10
years down the line uh yeah and kind of
look back say
have that brought enough value to enough
people are we proud of it right that was
kind of number one
north star
number two would be
uh
will we enjoy from from that process and
when it's part of
our
joy is this
small successes doing the way
and and kind of for me what what makes
me uh very happy is getting customer
feedback right and someone calling me
staying offer
your product works fantastic
uh it helped me in this this this and
this it saved me time money uh um
hopefully um in the world of cyber in
the world of healthcare save life or
improve life save the mindset
catastrophes
and
the third thing is
being successful in our world whether we
like it or not success is being measured
in two things a profitability of the
company to
evaluation exit ipo
i'm hoping that in this journey
profitability would be leading the way
rather than
the latter but i mean obviously today
you know there's a growing understanding
that the more in order to make the real
impact you know it's correlated
one-on-one with the profitability of the
business and that is how you make at the
end i think that that circulates back to
the north star of the company so you're
you're at that intersection and
something happens in in you know the
covet times that changes the world
changes the way people work changes the
way we interact with our companies with
our devices
what is what is the understanding that
that the two of you got to when you
started out
so
it was like that around june
uh when we kind of uh brainstormed june
2020 when we kind of brainstormed on
different ideas
uh the idea of talon uh came forward in
a very strong way understanding that
postcode there are
three trends that are
going to change dramatically for for the
next decade around world of 18 right
right the first one is the fact that
people
will work hybrid for the next
10 15 years
um
it will not be home only it will not be
office only could be distributed all
around the world we're going to be a lot
more agile around where did we work from
how
i remember there were ones that there
were endless articles of people debating
whether it would be all home all office
i kept thinking why obviously you know
it's going to be some model let's focus
on what we need to develop now to make
sure that that model works instead of
arguing whether it's all or nothing
right
for sure it will be it will be a hybrid
whatever mixture it will be yeah the
second point is around the explosion of
right so um
every single uh uh customer of ours
which we are discussing with saying look
we are either completed immigration to
stars or in
super uh speedy journey uh to do that or
we need somebody to help us do it
because we need to already do it exactly
and and number three is is the variety
of devices right because we have now
corporate devices personal devices
contractors uh third parties um
employees which are working from their
uh windows mac devices linux android ios
and and we try to think with all of
these three trends a water exchange
which obviously you have less visibility
you have less control you need something
that kind of gives you the same security
posture across every device but you also
need to be very respectful to employ
privacy
user experience becoming key
productivity is kind of becoming the
holy grail of everyone right so now
organizations stopped measuring uh how
much do employees are working but
everyone are focusing on productivity
what is the output out so we need things
which are helping this output to go
forward
and
with that kind of friend in mind is
there a commonality towards it and
that's what kind of the idea of browser
uh came to our mind
uh somewhere middle 2020 uh
but with this
just before we are committing our next
decade to software on id security
um
we post for a second head deck is kind
of this journey uh digital health care
uh so you had this idea before you went
to digital health care yeah we finally
went
wow
that's fascinating investing four months
really
on the world of digital healthcare
felt that will not be able to make the
impact that we want to do and then
somewhere in in in december uh we
decided that that's where we want to
focus the next uh decade and from there
it was i think that's also much part of
the maturity of the entrepreneurs saying
you know we have this great idea we're
not just gonna go tomorrow morning and
and go all out without having that
conviction let's make sure we we
understand what's happening scour the
landscape get that conviction and i'm
guessing that when you we went back to
this idea after four months of letting
it sit and bubble
the relationship with it was a little
bit healthier perhaps and a little bit
more mature exactly because i think that
when you're committed to something you
want to make sure that it's right for
you the inner conviction has to be
so strong so
i'm passionate about it i have a spark
in my eye that's what i want to do for
for the next 10 years and
i think
for us it was
so
important to make sure that
we did it with
kind of eyes wide open that's what we
want to be that's where we will be
bringing value to our customers
and i think that journey
made us a lot more uh whole right not a
lot more
mature about the idea about what we're
going to do for for many years now so i
think that
the route was critical
so december going back a few months
later
announcing the biggest sea round ever in
the israeli ecosystem 26 million dollars
to to start this journey and obviously
you know a lot of people are you know
know you and know your co-founder and
and and you know i think immediately
anybody that looks at what you're doing
you know it it makes sense i mean and it
made the tininess which is obviously so
much in the start world it's there and
the execution team the location is
beautiful but i want to get to know
often a little bit
and you as a leader
second time ceo
in argus you know you were leading teams
in in the idea of doing phenomenal
things at 8200
what are you taking from you sort of as
a manifest to yourself
as you're transitioning from argus to
this next journey and you're saying i'm
committing to another to now 10 years of
making an impact in this company
what else is all for bringing with him
from your previous experiences
i think the most important thing that
i've learned during that process
is
bring
people who are
a
leaders themselves um
be
super
i would say
mature in how they think they don't
necessarily need to have 20 years of
experience but necessarily they need to
be
uh with mature thinking um
very independent in in their
capabilities
and allow them to run a lot faster so
kind for the first time or i remember
that i was a lot more involved in every
single decision and and
uh now i'm kind of
making sure that whenever someone asks
me a question immediately
first i would like to understand your
your suggestion what do you think is
right and the number of times that you
kind of coming in and say
uh
no i i would like to do something
different has to always be reducing
because it means staying you've brought
the right people right and b these
people are are growing having the bigger
perspective they understand where the
company uh needs to get and when the
vision is articulated right where kind
of uh as you mentioned the north star
where do you wanna
do you wanna get um then everything is
moving a lot faster so bring the right
people and when i'm saying right it's
not necessarily professionally right
even more important would be
um
the right from the inside right good
people
friendly
fun
you don't hear those adjectives much
from from ceos that are looking for
their first talent that's it different
we're standing here so many hours
and then
look it's not the safe time i'm doing
that because uh otherwise i i won't have
i won't have work right i did it because
because
i want to
to build something him to enjoy the
wrong but why work so hard off that
you've done it it's a fun minute
it's a what it's a hobby it's in a sense
great things look it's it's people ask
me what's what's my vlog and i said
building things right working like work
is is it's fun right i'm i'm finishing
the day here let's say
10 p.m i continue home yeah
few minutes ago it told me a later hour
but i still keep 10 pm for now
then you know another two or three hours
potentially at
home but
in a sense
i do because i enjoy it not because i i
have to write i i
interaction with the people the
interaction with the customers
solving this problem problems right
thinking okay we got this feedback from
a customer uh we didn't name this this
this and this
the day tomorrow you have to come back
and think okay what what do i change
what do i want to do better how do i
learn from it how do i grow from it
in your kishke
inside
you're coming every day
you're
moving very very fast
does it feel different
are you different
certainly i think that i'm different in
how i think about things the maturity
how do i prioritize right
i just remember
in how many
decisions i was involved that
if i would have done it again i would
certainly wasn't uh involved in this
because
i think that we should be involved in
building the strategy
showing the compass were gonna go
um
having fantastic team to work with us
and
allow them the freedom uh to run us as
fast as they can
and the other point which is
generally in unfair advantage right
uh we're able today to attract a lot
stronger talent compared to to the
previous uh journey because
with with all respect to to where were
eight years ago
the talents that that we have here
not necessarily would have come work
with me in in the previous journey right
they
could have had
enough potential if there are
alternatives at that point and and now
you know
they trust a lot and i uh better they
feel that
uh
will be
uh a more receptive to their needs and
and and more open uh to their talent uh
to go out uh will allow them a lot more
freedom uh to run and execute and
hopefully we'll make uh better decisions
why not so
it's i think it's a little bit different
anyhow right i just have a cell phone
that i this inspires me and what really
inspires me beyond the fact that i think
you're building an incredible product in
the perfect timing in this perfect storm
which is a blessing and a curse for the
world and
again the maturity that i'm that i'm
getting and that the progression that
you're articulating here from the
initial trend which was also very very
successful but the lessons you're
learning especially as a leader and and
looking at yourself and continuously
improving both on the ideation phase
which was uh you know i think it's
amazing that he put it aside for a
little bit to try different things and
then got that conviction and came back
but then also on a day-to-day and how
you're managing the team and and you're
not just looking for the best engineers
but you're looking for the best leaders
that are also good engineers are also
good product managers but people who can
lift the organization and build the
right culture from the get-go all failed
this was amazing very much